this was our escort a small mechanized
fanuel fit on its way to a Terran
Republic frontline it was a long before
we were ambushed by new conglomerate
Special Forces
confusion and panic cost lives
reinforcements arrived within minutes
clearing the way forward a deadly
advance towards the terror Republic's
frontline
with heavy losses on both sides levan
who managed to push towards victory this
battle on endure may be over with the
battlefields of amaresh have just begun
new conglomerate forces attacking the
terror Republic's frontline
many outfits join together to weaken the
enemy
the advanced moves quickly with the
reinforcements already melting up moving
towards the next outpost
the terror Republic are known for their
persistence
the fighting that followed was intense
keeping the invading forces out with
deadly results
it's locked down for the two sides and
with the TR well dug in it's now an
uphill struggle for the Etsy the night
soon takes over this deadly attack and
the NC have pushed through but only to
be met by the awaiting heavy Terran
Republic reinforcements was a battle
that lasted long into the night
but it just wasn't enough to hold back
the NC forces
this all out war here on our axis and
with all factions deeply divided the
prospect of peace is a long way off
rubber Stoneman plan SI to our axis
you